according to morals and Dogma once you
have reached the 30th degree and the
31st 32nd and 33rd degrees then you know
that the one that you are worshiping is
Lucifer it states so absolutely you can
tell it to the Brethren of the 30th the
31st 32nd degree that Lucifer is the
true Son of
God hello everybody Welcome to to LED
live today we're going to talk about
secret societies but we have two South
Africans in the house
today welcome Walter VI to our Channel
once again um if you guys haven't
checked out some of his work we're going
to put a link in the description below
total Onslaught total Onslaught I mean
your work in Total Onslaught is one of
the reasons why I'm even sitting in this
table right now as a Christian um I had
walked away from God somebody shared
with me those videos and it just burst
my bubble it was such a good series
burst my bubble so if you like uh secret
societies watch totto Onslaught and uh
watch this video right here so we're
going to get into this topic a little
bit maybe you have some questions um
about this but we're going to have a
little discussion about this we'll put
some links to some videos if you want to
look more into this but um I always like
to start out like why is this relevant
to us today why would you say even
understanding this topic in any way
shape or form would this be relevant I
don't think you can actually understand
current events without taking secret
societies into
account because uh they are operative at
every single level of
society and they are the great movers
and shakers and influencers behind the
scenes we like to mock them you know the
bilderbergers are getting together again
and they're having that little chat
session MH but that's really where
decisions are made mhm and I mean why
would they get together and why would
they have all these secret meetings and
why would they be super secret and what
happens there and a lot of it is
conjecture but a lot of it can be traced
down to actual legislation and many many
of the presidents of the United States
have been involved in this when they've
been confronted in various different
news um Clips you know you see them I
can't talk about that it's kind of
secret you know and when you understand
like I remember seeing a picture I think
it was um Bush and and he was talking
about Skull and Bones I mean they're
laying you in a coffin
naked why would you even do something
like that you know what I mean well you
have to go back to the roots yes and
where does it come from and who was
actually involved in orchestrating them
so who is uh the head of all of this the
head of the secret societies really
because there there's a lot of flavors
but yeah I guess I guess let's start for
this because maybe there's some people
um in our audience that don't understand
or know they've heard the terms but
they're not quite sure what it is is
this is this one organization is it
layers of organizations like what's the
reason for all this secretive stuff you
can never have one organization because
if that should
fall then that would be gone so if you
looking at what's transpiring in the
world and somebody gets the blame then
you must know that that is a front
organization because the real blame will
never be laid where it actually belongs
so you have to dig deep and see where do
they actually come from who controls
them how do they control them and how
many layers are there it's like an onion
the more you peel the layers the more
are revealed and uh there you know it's
a very very big onion right right
seriously so many layers I mean you hear
about some of the like just like little
side subgroups but you know if I were to
name some of the top ones Masons
aluminati Jesuits I mean there's some
various different Jesuit Jesuit things
are are very historically documented
some of the reasons and things that that
they have been putting their hands in
various different political Arenas
around the world all right where did the
secret society start they started in the
anti- deluvian world they didn't start
just
recently meaning Before the Flood Before
the Flood now how do we how do we know
that like like they well if if you read
the writings the esoteric writings if
you take morals and Dogma for example by
Albert Pike MH then you will see that he
traces it back to Enoch but you have to
be very careful because in moral and
dogmas they have various dates and I
always find it fascinating that the
scientific World negates all of these
dates but the esoteric World Embraces
them interesting and what they Embrace
is a Biblical Paradigm and a time frame
as you would find it in the Bible
particularly the King James
Bible so if you take the the chronology
that you have in the King James Bible it
is exactly the same chronology as you
will find in do morals and dogma and it
talks about
anund which is the time from the
creation of the world and they trace the
secret societies back to Enoch H now
automatically when you hear about Enoch
you think about the good Enoch right the
one that walked with God the one that
walked with God seventh from Adam but if
you take the chronology as it is given
in in morals and Dogma for example you
will find that it's not the 17th from
Adam but Enoch son of Cain oh so so oh
wow you're you're going to open up a can
worms here oh yeah The Book of Enoch The
Book of Enoch is a is a different
apocryphal book that uh deals with many
of these issues and in that book for
example you have the sons of God having
relations with uh right the daughters of
men which is of course uh biblically
incorrect right because I understand
that as the um the daughters of of of uh
God right in the son of man Blended
together but they were the sons of God
and the daughters of men now the way
that is is those that followed God they
first separated themselves from those
that were living in the world and they
were called the sons of God and the ones
that came from the line of Cain they
were the daughters of men that's right
and then begin to mix yes so you know
they went to the mall to go and do
shopping saw the ladies in the minis
skirts and said wow these are great yeah
and then very soon they lost their
allegiance to God yeah but in the Book
of Enoch there are Heavenly beings that
have relations with humanity and the
funny thing is in modern translations in
the Bible you'll find exactly the same
thing MH whereas in uh the received text
you do not find that so there are
leanings towards esoteric writings and
apocryphal writings but we we're getting
off the point yeah so the first one to
inherit the secrets of of uh existence
as it were from an esoteric perspective
was Enoch son of Cain he's also the
first one that was um the father of a
city so he was a city dweller he created
the first cities H and that line was
very very prevalent and when Cain was um
banned from the presence of God then he
said you know this is more than than I
can take people are going to destroy me
and kill them and uh there's a book out
by tapa souri called rulers of evil and
if anybody wants to Enlighten themselves
a little bit about that man's
experiences then he should go and read
that book because it's very fascinating
and
basically it uh the title is also very
interesting rulers of evil so God put a
mark upon him which was The Mark of Cain
and that was the mark of authority it
wasn't a physical mark it was the mark
of authority to rule over the children
of evil so God allowed the children of
evil to rule over the children of evil
and the ones that ruled became engrossed
in the esoteric uh
philosophy namely the that you will
become God that you are like God you're
not inferior to God you set your own
norms and standards you don't need God
to tell you what's right and wrong
you're good enough to do that all by
yourself and uh yes and that you
certainly will not die you are Immortal
those are the three lies that were
articulated by the devil in Eden and
that's the basis of all esoteric
philosophy this philosophy
then in the anti- deluvian world was
spread far and wide until nobody
believed God anymore and everybody
believed the
esoteric philosophies what what is
esoteric philosophy can you explain that
well esoteric philosophy is a secret
philosophy that's why it's a secret
society now God in his wisdom gave man
the scriptures the word of God whereby
you can determine what is right and
wrong what is the way to live what is
morality what is truth and what is truth
and uh the esoteric writings negate that
they are the opposite of what the
scriptures said so if you if you read
Jesus in the scriptures they will
replace it with Lucifer so if you're
talking to an esoteric you might be
thinking you're talking to a Christian
because you might be talking about Jesus
but it's not not the Jesus Jesus means
yve saves but if you are God then you
can have a different perspective so
actually they're talking about the
lightbearer now Jesus says I am the
light of the world but there's another
one who says I'm the light bearer I am
the light of the world and that is
Lucifer that's what itday means so
esoteric Society at the very basis of
the philosophy or
luciferian so so this is kind of the
foundation for all of these secret
societies then like this is the
foundation of their belief the absolute
Foundation is the three lies of the
devil in the garden of e Eden you
determine your own
morality you are deity in yourself
therefore why should you be subject to a
deity and you will live forever you will
never be destroyed you are Immortal so
this comes out in various philosophies
in the world Many religious systems all
of them have as a basis the immortality
of the Soul even the Christian religion
has adopted it and uh or you become part
of narvana you become part of deity in a
in a in a pantheistic sense so that's
the basis of it and this progress then
all the way up until the destru ruction
in the
flood now we know that um ham for
example was not
exactly a very faithful uh individual
and we know nothing about the ladies
that they were married to some of them
could have been Daughters of men that
had been highly influenced by these
philosophies but God in his Mercy saved
three sons and their wives
and we assume that ham had some
philosophical ideas which were very akin
to what was there before because it
tells us in the scriptures that his
grandson
Nimrod was the one who was a warrior
before the Lord in other words against
the Lord interesting and he negated the
word of God by saying we will build a
tower yeah and we Babylon so so
basically they didn't believe God's
promise that he would not destroy the
flood the the Earth by water that's
really what the problem was at its core
that's the core you don't believe what
God Said you believe what the serpent
said which goes exactly all the way back
to the tree of the knowledge of Good and
Evil and it's like you know this problem
was being replicated on a grander scale
correct it's interesting because what
they were doing is they chose self right
when they made the tower Eve chose self
when she ate the fruit but choosing self
while they're trying to save themselves
and enhance themselves and become like
God is actually the destruction of
themselves that's right that's literally
what destroys who they are right mhm so
this is the progression then you get to
Nimrod and Nimrod became the
ruler but uh he was executed for his
crimes with his mother or what
or what was his crimes no probably the
line of uh the other two jaff and and S
probably had him executed for
propagating these ideas but you didn't
suppress it you actually made it
prominent and uh it the people were
scattered and there was this from then
onwards there is this constant movement
to unite Humanity in a single family
again with the same basic philosophy as
the esoterics had the worship of Lucifer
I have a theory on that I honestly
believe that what the devil is trying to
do is he's trying to basically overtake
this planet to the point that he can
snuff out anybody that's on God's side
so that he can turn around to God and be
like nobody in this place wants you
correct this is mine that's literally
what he's doing correct but he's never
succeeded in in that but he's been
working at it very very hard I mean we
can see that from The Book of Job right
it's like oh yeah I kind of own the
Earth you know walk to and fro and God
Is Like H you know I still got job have
you seen him you know he's still in my
side yeah yeah you're right yeah so this
is a constant battle behind the scenes
now because
Humanity uh accepts or accepted largely
the word of God they had to go
underground so the secret societies and
the esoteric societies have always
existed and they will always manipulate
the word of God perverted inverted I
call the devil the master of reversal he
reverses everything and in the esoteric
world when you start reading it you must
realize that whatever is good becomes
evil whatever is evil becomes good this
is where ying yang comes from narcissism
MH all of those issues yes and
narcissism BAS basically is the
character of De of the devil made
manifest in humanity w wow that's a good
description of that that's what what his
nature is like and since narcissism is
something that is rapidly on the
increase in the world and so many people
are subject to to that kind of uh
character
Behavior Uh it just shows that his
philosophy is certainly taking root in
humanity mhm and it's a very very
oppressive and a very uh forceful
situation but the war really is against
the word of God that's the basis of all
secret societies mhm how do you draw
people that are involved in the word of
God into societies that are at the very
core the antagonists to the word of God
and if this is like a a Christian
country
and all these guys are involved in this
yes you must have a lure you must have
something that draws them in so you make
them a social Society you make them a
business related Society capitalism but
you cches in
secrets and uh those secrets are
revealed one by one so you do it in
degrees so they have degrees various
degrees so masonry will for example go
up to 33° and there are you know
organizations that say they go well
beyond 33 degrees but according to
morals and Dogma once you have reached
the 30th degree and the 31st 32nd and
33rd Dees then you know that the one
that you are worshiping is Lucifer it
states so absolutely you can tell it to
the Brethren of the 30th the 31st 32nd
degree that loose is the true Son of God
mhm and they go that's right so so why H
how do these people can evolve like
we're talking about celebrities we're
talking about presidents and I know in
in total Onslaught you have evidence for
this you have document upon document
upon document that shows this but how
does this happen is it just like because
I know that uh Bush Jr was it right he
was involved in skull bones yes his
father too yeah so like they were both
Skull and Bones members and this was
happening at the University that they
were attending well the university has
uh clubs in it which are basically
secret society clubs so many of the
universities of course have esoteric
Origins we have to go to the point where
we get to that how did it happen MH
because universities were by and large
all started as uh schools of theology
mhm all of them wow they were Christian
they were
Harvard all those them but before that
they were you know run by other
organizations now how did how did this
actually happen well you have to trace
this um all the way through
history and how do we get to Modern
esoteric societies how do they come
about who actually controls them there
must be some controlling
organization so you have to go back to
the early ages where um you had a
religious system that absolutely
controlled the world and that was the
Roman Catholic system the Roman Catholic
system was the controlling factor in the
world and uh their dogmas and their
teachings were based on many Gnostic
documents so that's why you have two
streams in the Bible as well remember
you have the alexandrian stream and then
you have
the the the Eastern stream that comes
from Antioch so which of the streams do
you
utilize now Roman Catholicism based its
uh Bible on Jerome's vgate which in turn
Orient originated from Oregon's writings
via
eusebius and that particular stream was
rejected by the Reformation so that's
cutting it really short now M so the
Reformation based its Bible and its
scripture on the received text so Martin
Luther used that and the Protestants
come from the Reformation so if you're
Protestant this is what was coming out
of that yes so let us say that uh the
manuscripts that eventually ended up in
the Western World from the Eastern
manuscripts were used by the
reformation and the Reformation came to
the conclusion that Jesus Christ was the
only way to Salvation there was no other
name under Heaven and Earth whereby you
may be saved and uh that your
righteousness is an imputed and imparted
righteousness that you have no
righteousness of your own and this is of
course totally contrary to esoteric
thinking where you are a deity in
yourself MH mhm so these Concepts were
at war with it Each Other M and they
they led to a literal War the 30-year
war and uh this was an attempt to wipe
out protestantism mhm and they they
could not succeed in wiping out
protestantism it was a it was a a thorn
in the flesh of the superiority of of
the papal system so what they did is
they created an organization which was
called the
Jesuits and it was founded by three
individuals the one was Ignatius Lola
who was a Spaniard who had
visions of how to reintroduce papal
Supremacy in the world and these these
were based on esoteric Visions M and
then you had another individual he was
the intellectual one behind the the
scenes he was a German his name was
petaa and then you had s Fran uh Francis
zavia those three were the founding
fathers of the Jesuits and the whole
purpose was to try to destroy the the
Protestant protestantism the aim was to
destroy protestantism and to get rid of
the Protestant version of the Bible h of
of the New Testament text from the re CE
T so that was that was the aim and uh
they formed the society which was
basically a secret society and crazy
they called it the Society of Jesus yeah
yeah it was just a complete cover up I
mean this is the reversal that they're
constantly doing right we're going to
destroy the Bible the real truth of it
and we're going to call ourselves Jesus
followers they they they called the
Bible that poisonous ASP wow and uh they
said one day like Moses's Rod will grab
it by the tail and we will destroy it
wow now uh the papal family at that time
was a family by the name of manini mhm
and the popes were all in that category
and the maninis had a very interesting
origin and they had gathered the Greek
philosophy and esoteric writings of all
the centuries into one Great
Library which was based on esoteric
thinking in other words the philosophy
that the serpent had which is the
opposite of the biblical one so this
philosophy was then embraced by the
Jesuits and their aim was to infiltrate
the political sphere the entertainment
world and the religious sphere and to
undermine the precepts of protestant ISM
and to destroy
protestantism and they took an oath that
they would destroy it even through
assassination by whatever means possible
to destroy it now their philosophy is
not a new philosophy it comes from Enoch
son of Cain all the way through history
it is the basic philosopher that Lucifer
is the true Son of God
mhm and this
philosophy became part in Apostle of
their philosophy but how do you
introduce it you Garb it in a robe of
Christianity yeah and that's interesting
because a lot of people at home don't
know that if you look up the origins of
the Catholic Church they're a mixture of
pagan like you said Garb with
Christianity those statues that you see
that are supposedly Saints they were
just Roman gods that they said well now
this one's going to be Peter and this
one's going to be St John and Etc
correct if you if you look them all up
they're all Pagan deities and all those
Pagan deities in inverted commas all
taught the same
philosophy now the the Roman Catholic
church had always had
societies that propagated this this um
philosophy and also aimed at the power
structure to control every aspect of
humanity and if you control the banking
system if you control the finances you
have a pretty good grip on things mhm so
they were for example the
Templars the Templars were an
organization that was supposedly you
know going to secure the temple ground
in Jerusalem etc etc for Christianity
but they became the bankers of Europe
that's why they're called the Templars
as they were trying to retake the temple
yes that was also the Crusades and all
of these things that went before before
the
Reformation so they woried a deity which
was called Buffet mhm and Buffet is of
course the androgenic deity
Lucifer who is both male and female
that's why it's a very interesting time
that we are living in yes it is because
I just find it very really interesting
that we have this series out called The
Chosen and he's a night's
Templar if they're following B met I
mean that's interesting that's right and
he's literally playing Jesus correct so
I mean that's like the Jesuit Playbook
right they're trying to infiltrate
everything either by force or deception
yes yeah yeah we could go into a long
discussion about those but let's not go
there yeah no no the fact of the matter
is they became the bankers of
Europe and that meant they became the
bankers of the world mhm and uh the king
of France then became jealous so the
story goes and he banned them and he he
killed or had them destroyed the
Templars but the Templars were never
destroyed mhm and the Templars had as a
leader one called
demole now it's very interesting that if
you go to the modern societies and the
modern Freemasons their Youth
Organization is called demole Oh serious
now why would they name themselves after
the very individual that was supposedly
a worshipper of Ba OH interesting and
Baff is Al of course the symbol that is
used by the Church of Satan when they
put up the statue of the goat with theh
they wanted to like put up the Ten
Commandments in some of the places and
they started putting the baffet up there
yeah and that's interesting that there's
literally two children looking up at
baffet as if it's like their father or
whatever which comes back to what you're
saying what they believe that he is the
true Son of God and he's the life Bearer
who's going to give them eternal life in
living in sin though not living
according to God's Commandments yes and
if you if you look at some of the modern
presidents of the United States uh one
that comes to mind is Bill Clinton he
was very prominent in the demolay
movement interesting so that just that's
just an aside but this
philosophy never disappeared and you
will find it
underground in the rosac crucians for
example what is that it's a it's an
order of people that it bases itself and
they all modeled interestingly on the
model of Jesus and his disciples so the
number 13 becomes very very important
because of the 12 disciples and then uh
maias was added later on after Judas
killed himself so yes so you had Jesus
in the center and then you had the
12 they model themselves as 12 around
one yeah so you have groups of 13 and
etc etc they're all based on an
antithetical view of what scripture was
all about right you'd think that they
would come up with something original
look if you want to do something
different right you go off in the corner
of the the world and you just do
something like whatever totally
different why are they mimicking it's
like the only thing that they can do is
take the truth of God and pervert it no
because the war is against Jesus Christ
that is the pivot of the entire War MH
and what we are seeing in the world
today is just coming into the open of
that which was practiced secretly MH mhm
so in any case so the Jesuits decided
that they had to reinstate papal
Supremacy so the First Council that was
called to um oppose Protestant ISM was
the Council of Trent and at the Council
of Trent every single dogma of the
papacy was firmly established and the
dogma of papal
infallibility was um the ground basis
for the power of the papacy from that
period
onwards and also very interesting one of
the issues was the Sabbath H at the
Council of Trent they were debating and
the were many protest Protestants
present at that meeting and some of the
Catholic were inclined to agree with the
Protestants that the Bible was to be the
basis for what One Believes and
Catholicism said no the Bible can only
be uh described in relation to
tradition and then the Archbishop of
Regio got up and he said now excuse me
Protestants you say that the the Bible
and the Bible alone is your is your
standard then why do you keep Sunday
which is a command of the Roman Catholic
church so you are actually obeying the
authority of the church and therefore
your solar scriptura is meaningless you
can't get away with that and there was a
wonderful opportunity for the for the
Protestant world to say wow you actually
touched the nerve there MH but they
didn't and then the Jesuits expanded and
they worked themselves into positions of
power they became the counselors of
kings and they started uh the movement
to become the school masters of
Europe so they became the school Masters
they became the uh centers of learning H
so they created school after school
after school H and even the Protestants
sent that children to these Roman
Catholic Jesuit run schools and today
when you go through the world you will
find these Jesuit controlled places all
over the world like where Oxford well
all the
universities that were there when
protestantism took over the Protestant
portions they became Protestant schools
so Oxford was a Protestant School
Cambridge was a Protestant School V B
University in EUR in Germany was a
Protestant school so the idea was we
must infiltrate them so we will become
the best Protestant that we can become
and we will turn it around So
eventually they turned them around and
and uh
removed this obstacle this Protestant
way of thinking uh the most important
prominent one was the Oxford movement
mhm where you had uh Newman who was a
Protestant in adverted commas preacher
that took the whole of Oxford and put
the theology back on a track with the
Roman Catholic thinking wow yeah so they
slowly brought in the statues again and
then they brought in an altar because an
altar is something where you to make a
sacrifice right now Roman Catholicism
has always denied the atonement that
Jesus died for you really yes R Roman
Catholicism doesn't is that why the
wafer is like really a is sort of like a
Rec crucifying it's a Rec crucifying you
see you must understand Catholic
theology in order to understand that
it's not a Christian religion it's a
garbed Christian religion I mean I mean
this sounds terrible to all the
Catholics out there well you're one cath
you're speaking from your own experience
I want to throw that out there that you
grew up in this I was a Roman Catholic
raised yes but uh you must understand
the philosophy Roman
Catholicism teaches that Jesus died but
he didn't die for you he died as the
ultimate example of obedience wow and
you are not saved by the blood of the
Lamb there is no blood involved in your
salvation it's your works you are saved
by your work yeah and therefore they
deny uh justification by faith so
Council of Trent made that very clear so
now if you are not saved by the blood of
the Lamb how are you saved you are saved
by your good works now you are guilty
you inherit according to them Adam's
original sin so you inherit original sin
so you are guilty how do you atone for
that guilt well firstly you have to
confess your sins but you do not confess
them to God you confess them to the
system you confess them to a priest MH
then you are forgiven by the priest of
your sin but you still bear the guilt of
your sin now according to the Christian
doctrine of the Bible Jesus Paid that
price for you and the guilt that is
supposed to be on you he bore on your
behalf and then he imputes his
righteousness and imparts his
righteousness to you not in the Catholic
system you still bear the guilt so now
you have to pay for that guilt how do
you pay for that guilt well there's a
Greek philosophy of purgation where you
get rid of that guilt so the doctrine of
purgatory is where you in the afterlife
go to this intermediary place which is
called purgatory and there you pay for
your sins by suffering for as long as
your sins are not burnt away yet M now
that could take a millennium or two for
a short life of maximum of 70 years or
so so but for $24.99 you can actually
shorten that you know you can pay for
the shorten verion so this was a a
doctrine that caused a lot of
consternation so the papacy came up with
uh an Indulgence
now an Indulgence is something where the
pope can grant you
Merit and he can impute that Merit to
you in return for something mhm now in
the time of Martin Luther the return was
of a monetary nature so you paid and
then you got an Indulgence which
relieved you from the punishment of the
guilt of your sins what are we talking
here in terms of payment like
do you have numbers like uh do we know
how much they were saying they were
paying the exact amounts varied
according to what you had but the idea
was as soon as the money clinks in the
Box a spirit is relieved from the
penalty of purgatory so they can kind of
keep you on a subscription basis yeah so
how could the pope actually apply Merit
now this is where very interesting
Doctrine comes in which is not biblical
at all this is All Greek
philosophy uh the doctrine that he has
is that he has access to something which
is called the treasury of Merit wow now
in this Treasure Chest that he has
access to you have the Merit of Jesus
Christ but you also have the Merit of
Mary and all the
saints so you can take of that Merit in
other words they were so
meritorious that they did more than was
necessary to go to heaven so they have
excess Merit and that excess Merit goes
into this chest now you and I as
terrible Sinners don't have excess Merit
merits or need to pay in purgatory so
now the pope has the power to take of
that Merit and apply it to you for
something that you must do in return so
even the even Pope Francis has just
given out a Indulgence I know what
you're thinking absolute counterfeit
you to know what I'm talking about yeah
Paula White no okay you're think of
something else do you know who Paula
White is yes absolutely Paula White she
was she's a Evangelical mega church
pastor and she was the uh spiritual
adviser of trump during his presidency
is this blonde lady yes it is so I saw
this video where she literally said God
has storehouses in heaven and you better
pay up you know $200 $30
$30,000 and you need to put that into
this Storehouse and this treasury
because otherwise you're not going to
your dreams are not going to be
fulfilled and this and that and that and
I'm like wow and it's the same thing
there's a Department of Treasury in
heaven that God is watching over
everything you do and you are storing up
Eternal treasure that will go so far
beyond I think that we can even begin to
imagine you need to send in
$3500 you need to send in $35,000
you need to send in that $100,000 check
if you do not write that PO box and you
do not call that toll-free number and
you do not become a Ministry of
sustainer you will never see sustainment
in your life and your dream will die
your call will die the Catholic Doctrine
has seeped into protestantism among
other means through the Jesuits correct
and where does it come from It's Greek
philosophy it's paganism in inside
protestantism so in other words Roman
Catholicism is not a Christian religion
because a Christian
religion says that you are saved by the
blood of the Lamb right without the
shedding of blood there's no forgiveness
of sins right now if Rome negates it
then they are teaching actually a
luciferian Doctrine and their own
catechism says the Son of Man became man
so that we can become god wow like he
came down so you could go up I mean
there there's so many counterfeits here
merits of what Jesus did and that we can
reach out by faith and take it on I mean
look at that just counterfeit left and
right but it's like removing Jesus
correct so the Jesuits then started uh
the learning against learning so they
would take philosophy and make that the
basis of all
teaching now if you had a very Christian
view like Martin Luther said if you
remove the Bible then from the from the
teaching then we will we will lose it
all and that's exactly what they did so
what they did is they removed the Bible
they allowed a
theological department but the rest
became secular so all universities
became
secular so in in Oxford the Oxford
movement brought back the Catholic
system brought back the mass and
eventually new
walked over to the Catholic church and
he was rewarded by being a cardinal wow
so he left protestantism and became a
Catholic Cardinal so he was actually in
my opinion a something like a Jesuit
infiltrator at what level do these
Cardinals understand what they're a part
of once you get to the level of a
cardinal you must be like in a secret
society pretty much informed so those
pictures of of the Catholicism where you
see them in purple and Scarlet very
interesting Scarlet I mean when you see
the pictures and you're like wow the
Bible just described exactly what this
entity looks like it's pretty crazy yes
but they're fully aware correct and the
way in which they captured the
mind was through Jesuit theater this is
where you come in Hollywood there was a
Jesuit and his name was Kino H now in
German Kino is a bioscope is a theater H
and he in invented an instrument which
through flashing lights could cast
images on a screen interesting and that
became the movie wow produc so yes so
the Jesuits became not only the school
Masters they also became the masters of
the theater
wow and they were the first Master Class
yes and where they couldn't infiltrate
directly they used the theater now
there's a high probability that
Shakespeare might not even have been a
literal person but was a pseudonym for
someone in the high esoteric circles
like s Francis Bacon for example and he
was a rosar crucian so he would have a
high esoteric and would probably be able
to write something like MC Beth or or
one of them MH and once you divert the
Mind into this esoteric fairy tale world
then you can implant anything else now
that's your line so going to go there ex
you're speaking my language but that is
one thing that I think really is tying
all of these different I mean you think
of all the different production
companies all the different people
involved all the different span I mean
there's there's armies of people how are
you getting all their messages similar
Army is a very good name now the Jesuits
are also a military
organization I was thinking about that
Napoleon called the Jesuits an army
instead of a religious organization well
Napoleon was a high was a high Mason
because he put all of his his family
into high uh secret society positions
that being as it as it may they then
created all the Great Schools like
Georgetown University or fordam
University or many of them are not
directly linked to them but actually
through the committee's controlled by
them so let's say that a large
proportion of the of the world of
Education today is based on the
philosophy of the Jesuits mhm and they
are the ones that train the presidents m
whether that be uh whoever Donald Trump
yeah there's there's enough evidence out
there that they have all been Parts in
they've all been part of it we don't
have to go into all of them but the yes
they're all somehow Associated and
trained in this and they are high Masons
mhm is it the same Jesuits and Masons
are the same no okay Masons are an
organization that at its basis should
actually be protest
but this is the beauty of the deception
you create an organization then you ban
it right so Rome make it intriguing Rome
officially banned the Masonic order and
said it was of the devil all Masons are
from the devil while every single
Cardinal in the Vatican was a Mason yeah
so pretty hypocritical that's pretty
hypocritical they're true though that's
true so that is how you draw them in as
long as you at the top yeah controlling
the situation and controlling the
teachings then you have drawn in the
Protestant world and you are actually
controlling it without them knowing it
so I think from what I remember from
watching your total Onslaught series is
that the Roman Catholic Church
technically is at the helm of all these
secret societies yes how how so how come
well they have these two two orders the
one that that still REM
to this day and that is the Jesuit order
which has a general which is generally
called the black
pope and uh he has absolute Authority
and do we know who this black pope is
yeah it's public knowledge currently
yeah yes and they've they change
regularly as time goes on but they
basically their power is absolute and
then you have the um Knights of Malta
the Knights of Malta are also military
order both of them are military orders
now if you if you take the Knights of
Malta they have the males cross but
they're subject to the
Jesuits so there were actually physical
Wars in order to control this issue So
eventually the Knights of Malta became
subject to the Jesuits and they they
work in unity and then you have many
suborders within the the Opus day and
all of these that also swear allegiance
to the papacy or the Knights of Columbus
which are a Catholic
organization uh promising to bring
Catholic ideas into politics etc etc and
you belong to one or the other and if
you look at the history of presidential
candidates they will either come from a
opda background or Georgetown background
or a forham background or any one of
those so the Knights of Malta are a huge
organization and they have they call
themselves the hospitals of St John's
and they have the malse cross as their
symbol now if you take the kings of
Europe they all wear malse crosses
they're they're nothing other than
vassels to the pope MH and uh they
control vast organizations and vast
Financial organizations and probably
most of the great uh theaters and sports
clubs they all are owned and controlled
I wouldn't say all but the majority
controlled by Knights of Malta that
brings the
philosophy into the world how do people
get involved in these things
money you're wealthy you're going to rub
shoulders with people that are involved
in these things going to get a good deal
and we're we're a philanthropic Society
we do good to society and we have
uh organizations from which we draw our
people so you can start with uh Boy
Scout Girl Scout the all of these
organizations they're all
basically feeders to this organiz and I
remember seeing something I don't
remember if it was from your ministry or
what but about the um the uh Greek
systems that are in the colleges yes
also handpicking people and basically
priming their fil systems so you're
watching people go through this thing
and then they're like hey this guy shows
um you know good signs in this area or
whatever like that and then they can
know who's going to stick it out in this
secret society yes and and you can just
watch their symbols and you can see all
right now you have a club that is let's
say a humanitarian club like the Lion's
Club or the rotarians or any one of them
or the upside down star or the star or
what whatever that one was yes or even
pH opical discussion
societies but in those you have someone
who is higher up in another chapter and
they will
draw their basis from from these groups
and invite them up higher and then you
get invited up higher and you spoke to
me a little bit earlier about something
weird about people lying in a coffin and
getting up etc
etc that is a a counterfeit of
baptism wow good interesting connection
there so you're actually dying yeah and
then you're called out of of that oh
yeah but they're still like not washing
with water there's no water in there
it's there's no water interesting
interesting yes now if you take the
Catholic system in the old days probably
still today if you became a monk or a
nun you went through the coffin
experience there the there is videos out
there of people that caught video of
them and they're screaming I mean you
hear this like
demonic weird well they're probably
possessed we we don't have to go into
the details of what ever happens there
some of the things are really quite
horrendous if you start investigating
Rabbit Hole yes but uh they would be
tonsured for example in the old days the
nuns and the monks were tonged there was
a a symbol of the suffering that Nimrod
went through now Nimrod when he died or
when he was executed he actually Rose
and became part of the sun MH the Sun
God and then he came and he
impregnated
seirus and uh semiramis was the one who
gathered his his body parts but one of
them was missing a very important one
especially if you wanted to bear his
child so she fashioned one oh and this
became the phallic symbol which is
basically the Spire that you have the
Obelisk that's in front of Obelisk all
political buildings
and and then she bore a son who became
the Savior and this is the same that you
had in in all the ancient Pagan
religions so mother and child worship
became very important which you see in
all different cultures right yes and
those you had mariology in Roman Cath
iism counterfeit of the prophecy that a
woman will have a baby that yes yes so
if you take the Jesuit Bible for example
the DU Rhymes Bible and you have the
promise of the Messiah then uh the King
James will say and I'll put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed and he shall crush
your head in the je Rhymes it'll be she
shall crush your head so that it becomes
Mary and not not the Messiah now I we we
did a video a couple of weeks ago um
with James Bowen he is the religious
liberty leader at his church and he is a
very well versed uh individual in
Christian history and so we did a video
on the Jesuits and he showed document
document document document to expose
exactly who they are I was talking about
this video with a friend and she said
well how do we know that this is all
this is all history how do we know that
this is exactly still what they're doing
today to destroy protestantism that
they're in all these places Etc I mean I
know you have a load of evidence in
total Onslaught but could you share a
little bit of that well if you if you
look at the uh organizations that uh
control the world like the secret
society or the secret police of the
world whether that be the KGB whether
that be the CIA whether that be the FBI
who founded them they were Knights of
Malta uh
Donovan Knight of Malta uh
Bonaparte Knight of Malta they were they
are 100% Catholic controlled
organizations mhm so we know that uh you
don't get into positions of power within
those organizations if you do not have
those connections and ultimately they
are worshippers of Lucifer yes so it's
the same thing is the same temptation as
Jesus had where Satan said I'm going to
uh give you the whole world if you bow
down to me and he said no but these
people are like sure I believe your lie
which I think is truth and they do it so
let's take let's take masonry if you get
to the 32nd
degree then uh you know very well that
Lucifer is the true Son of God in
adverted commas and if you are at the
32nd degree then you can become part of
an organization that is called the
Shriners now the Shriners wear
aairs and uh they swear Allegiance
according to their Affairs even to
Allah so uh if you go to a masonic
temple on their altar you will find all
the
books uh that are in religious teachings
today you will find a copy of the Bible
you will find a copy of the Quran you
will find a copy of the Sarita you will
find a copy of the Jewish tanak they're
all on the altar so they are in
principle an
ecumenical
group now if you want to be in an
ecumenical society that means ecumenism
at its very basis has the philosophy
that you have to accept the papacy as
primate so if you go sign a document the
charter ecumenica you acknowledge in
that document that you acknowledge the
Pope's primate now that's exactly what
is restoring what was lost in the Middle
Ages right yep that's what that that
Catholic priest Tony when he came on
that Protestant uh um Kenneth Copeland's
thing he said these churches have signed
this document basically giving
Allegiance back to com back to the
mother church is what they say all right
now once you once you have uh joined
such an organization and you know that
uh the Jesus Christ that they worshiped
did not die for
you is that then the same Jesus Christ
that died for you mhm just because you
take the name Jesus into your mouth
doesn't mean it's the same Jesus that we
read about in the Bible and if you know
the thinking of the esoteric world if
you read the writings of blavatsky for
example she will tell you straight out
that you have to read the Bible
esoterically and that the basis is the
cabala the
cabalistic philosophy at the very heart
is that we are all
deity now if you are all deity then you
have no
origin because you are God you are
self-existent then the Sabbath becomes
meaningless because the Sabbath is there
to remind you that you
are a created being originating from the
power of God M and that we are going
through the sanctification process
exactly because Jesus wants to save us
so automatically you have to negate the
Sabbath and that's where we come into
what you wanted to speak about as you
wanted to speak about the the the green
Sabbath that we're talking about today
which by default has to be a day other
than the seventh day Sabbath so it it
gets very involved but at the heart all
secret society are a rebellion against
God mhm and the rulers of the world are
the rulers of evil that have the
authority via the L line of Cain m which
is The Mark of Cain which is the mark of
authority interesting now if you go to
Roman Catholicism they say the mark of
our
ecclesiastical Authority is that we have
transferred the Sabbath to the Sunday
therefore if you obey the Sunday you are
paying homage to the authority of the
Roman Catholic church so who are the
rulers of evil that want to supplant God
it is the Roman Catholic system who
through their secret societies and
control of all others like the
Illuminati was started by Adam vop who
was a Jesuit they'll say he was a a
renegade Jesuit there's no such thing
right there's no such thing right I I
I've been doing some research into the
theosophical society theosophy and
blotsky and Alicea Bailey because I'm
trying to create a show and um it's
interesting that
the connection between the theosophy and
what they believe and for example the
United Nations they want the one world
religion one world religion One World
Government but the beliefs of blavatsky
and Alice Bailey and theosophy is like
you said esoteric it's the same root and
it's androgenic you have to blend male
and female right but then like what you
know when we look at all of this that
you've spoken about everything goes down
a funnel to prophecy being fulfilled
where if you want to have the mark of
the beast how can you do that unless you
have a one world religion yes that's the
root of it all I mean the cause correct
and everything comes from underneath MH
now according to scripture that's the
bottomless pit from which everything
evolves and even if you take Alice in
Wonderland for example she goes down a
rabbit hole she goes down a hole and she
finds her inspiration down in the bottom
this pit these are all esoteric writings
whether it's tolto or whoever these are
rosac crucian uh philosophies that you
find in these writings and they're made
prominent by Jesuit Theater which is
Hollywood and as you know Holly is of
course witchcraft the the Witchcraft
staff the wood so it all points back to
the rulers of this world
who have to Center on one individual who
negates the teachings of Jesus Christ
that's why it's called Antichrist
spiritualism at its core Garden of Eden
you got a snake the snake is obviously
the devil speaking through the snake and
you know God says don't eat he says eat
so all spiritualism can be distilled
down into a very simplistic form it's
changing the words of God yes you can
recognize spiritualism right off the bat
when you go the Bible says this but
that's saying that now you have to be
careful for a double
deception because you can have
Christianity which is bible-based
supposedly MH but if the rules and
regulations that are applied do not come
from the Bible but from the system
itself then it is a
counterfeit so we have for example a
movement now like in the state of
Philadelphia Etc to put the Ten
Commandments back into the school school
rooms MH now I have no problem with the
Ten Commandments as long as that the Ten
Commandments that come from the Bible
but if you've been indoctrinated to
believe in the version that comes from
the Roman Catholic
catechism then you are actually
accepting a counterfeit and negating the
word of God was that one of the ones
that they were putting in there was a
Catholic like they put them in there but
let's take the fourth Commandment when
they say the Sabbath day what are they
referring to the biblical seventh day or
the Catholic first day of the week right
they call it the Lord's day they put it
back up and then they reinterpret what
that means they re interpret it yes
interesting so you can have a double
deception you have to be very very
careful you think that you're following
God like that's what we're told in the
end right there's a bunch of class of
people that think they're running around
doing God's work and they're really
fighting against those that keep the
Commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus that's why the Jesuits say
you're paying homage to the papacy if
you keep the Sunday it's interesting
like we you got Jesuit theater and then
now you got even like you know Bible
biblical interpretation you got Banks
you got government got everything it
gives a whole new meaning to all roads
lead to Rome what is RO what is the rth
childes you know everybody's always
looking at either the zionists or uh the
Rothchilds for controlling the world
Rockefellers yeah Roth child comes from
the German R Shield which means red
shield if you look it up in the Catholic
encyclopedia it means Bankers of the
Pope so in other words they are a front
organization which control the banking
system the Bank of America is owned
directly by the Jesuits they call the
shots and they consider themselves to be
Christian right I mean they're putting
their face out there that they're doing
these Christian things cuz I remember
seeing videos and being like what I I
always thought the Rothchilds were like
the the ones that like have the the
basement rooms into the Vatican and they
were doing the sacrificing of the
children and you know like evil stuff
yes well if you want to know who
controls the world and how they control
it there are only three entities in the
world which are independent of political
systems one is the the Vatican MH the
other one is the center of London which
is a city in itself which is the
economic Hub of the Jesuit world and
then you have the military Hub which is
Washington DC and the White House stands
on Jesuit ground oh it's all Jesuit all
Catholic in thean everything is Jesuit
everything connects to the Vatican so is
that why they have Stonehenge yes
absolutely right there near London
Stonehenge is just part of the old
esoteric Sun worship right but uh the
banking system is a state of on its own
it is not controlled through any system
of the British government it is an
independent with it state with its own
flag and its own Constitution just like
the Vatican wow so what would you say to
our viewers out there that are like look
never heard of this before like what are
you guys saying what would you tell
somebody that like what's the reason to
at least know a little bit about this
subject and and to know like where this
stuff is coming from if if somebody goes
why should I care let's say it boils
down to a great controversy between
Christ and
Satan uh we have a blueprint as to what
is truth it is called the Bible but you
have to read your Bible as it stands and
believe it as it stands out there in the
world you have rulers of evil who might
appear to be Christian and some of them
probably are and unbeknown to them are
trapped in syst sys that they do not
fully understand the origins of mhm but
this war has gone has come all the way
from the Garden of Eden right up until
the present time and uh I believe God
wants us to make a choice and if I get
myself involved in secret societies I'm
dabbling in something that I have no
control of so my advice is stay away
from secret societies of any shape or
form because Jesus said said I have done
nothing in secret amen and uh God Is
Open Secret is something that is from
the devil amen if I can add to that for
those at home having T discussed a lot
about the Jesuits the Catholic Church
you have a video about the Jesuits on
our Channel go check it out also we have
a video showing you from the Bible um
and and how prophecy has been fulfilled
in history what the beast power is the
Antichrist and what the mark of the
beast is so if you hear all of this and
you think there's something fishy about
the Roman Catholic Church as a system
we're not talking about genuine
Catholics who are at the bottom of the
totem pole who don't know we're talking
about the system go check out those two
videos and it will explain a whole lot
more thank you guys for watching and we
are also going to put some links to
Walter VI his ministry clash of the
minds what the work that you're doing
with Martin and um you guys are bringing
in some really current events right now
making sense for a lot of us so check
out these guys' Channel It's amazing And
um we thank you so much for joining us
and it's a pleasure I hope I didn't put
the cat amongst the
pigeons but uh please like subscribe
send this video to somebody that you may
think might benefit from this and if you
have a comment a question we do read
through those comments and so if we can
answer them we will do our best to do
that so definitely um engage with us
pray for us you can check out some of
our merch that we have on lightwear Dosh
shop where your witness we honestly
believe if you're going to promote
something why not put a Bible verse on
your chest and let people know which
side you actually stand on but as always
keep your eyes focused on Jesus that is
the most important thing that that you
can hear out of a conversation like this
it's a dark rabbit hole out there in the
world and the best thing that we can do
is keep our nose in the right book and
also keep our eyes on Jesus we love you
guys we'll see you guys next
week I'm sorry do we know each other it
seems like maybe we've met before I
don't know this is uh it's awkward
though just as much for me as it is for
you I really wish I had a conversation
[Music]
starter oh hey what's on my shirt and
this is the story of the Three Angels
message from Revelation 14 wow that
totally worked you know if you have
trouble starting conversations like me
maybe you should try lightwear
[Music]
welcome to the video Bible study Series
where we will explore a variety of Bible
topics using video and print what is
humility do we need God's law can I
understand the Holy Spirit yes you can
and we're going to solve that today in 5
minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a 5minute video
having a discussion on the topic and
Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has
activities overall we develop this
project for you to have a closer walk
with Jesus as you explore relevant
topics either in a group setting or on
your own we hope you find these a
blessing if you want more information go
to
www.light studios. TV or find us on your
favorite social media platform
oh
[Music]